that's good
Ryan Cranston goes undercover in the
infiltrator and another exciting role
was just announced
Zordon in the Power Rangers reboot can I
talk about one other role that just was
announced Jordan Power Rangers
yes that's well I was on set I found a
bunch NDA so I can't say much about what
I saw but I am very excited for you to
take on that role come on are you gonna
be doing mocap or video yes it's it's a
motion caption and it's a lot of CGI
work the the tenant of that storyline is
that this is a real person who was
trapped in this either world that you
know and then it becomes this in the
wall so to speak of this of this layer
command center command center gonna and
that he still has a heart and mind but
an agenda that he's got to get these
five Power Rangers to defend and the
earth or else everyone they know will be
killed so it's exciting
I'm so excited sure you're booming
Zordon voice the Rangers Rangers no man
I don't want to make it to clarity let's
get ready to Rangers a lot of people
don't know you were a part of the
original series woods yeah I did nothing
I did nothing for them like 35 years ago
things are coming full circle man